antes de hablar del estiramiento
simétrico y asimétrico analicemos el
espectro y erc para la divina mina esta
es la estructura de la div útil amina
empecemos por dibujar una línea en los
3000 números de onda del lado derecho
esperamos encontrar la señal para el
estiramiento del enlace carbono
hidrógeno donde el carbono tiene una
hibridación sp3 entonces esta es la
región que corresponde al enlace con
hidrógeno y observen que aquí tenemos
otra señal podemos decir que se
encuentra en un número de onda de aquí
tenemos 31 32 33 aproximadamente a los
3300 números de onda y corresponde a
otro átomo unido a un hidrógeno esta
señal corresponde al estiramiento del
enlace nitrógeno hidrógeno
este enlace esta es la señal del
estiramiento del enlace nitrógeno
hidrógeno ahora comparemos la fuerza de
ese enlace con la de un enlace carbono
hidrógeno donde el carbono tenga una
hibridación sp3 sabemos que el número de
onda depende de dos cosas depende de la
constante de fuerza acá y de la masa
reducida
entonces la masa reducida para estos dos
enlaces es aproximadamente igual si
calculamos la masa reducida del enlace
nitrógeno hidrógeno y la del carbono
hidrógeno obtendremos aproximadamente el
mismo valor así que lo que afecta a
estas señales es la constante de fuerza
acá y como la señal para el enlace
nitrógeno hidrógeno aparece en un número
de onda alto eso significa que es un
enlace fuerte porque si aumentamos la
constante de fuerza del enlace
aumenta el número de ondas aumenta la
frecuencia entonces el enlace nitrógeno
hidrógeno es más fuerte que el enlace
carbono hidrógeno donde el carbono tiene
una hibridación sp3 y como es más fuerte
necesitamos más energía para estirar ese
enlace
hablemos rápidamente de la energía la
energía es igual a la constante de
planck h por la frecuencia entonces
podemos decir que la energía de un fotón
es igual a h no donde no es la
frecuencia y como ya sabemos la
frecuencia es igual al número de onda
por la velocidad de la luz
entonces si tomamos esto y lo
sustituimos acá podemos ver que la
energía es directamente proporcional al
número de onda
es igual a h por el número de onda por
la velocidad de la luz y esta es una de
las razones por la que los espectros y r
se miden en números de onda se
relacionan con la energía si aumentamos
el número de onda aumenta la energía y
conforme nos movemos hacia acá
aumentamos el número de onda y por lo
tanto aumenta la energía entonces
podemos decir que se necesita más
energía para estirar un enlace fuerte
así que se necesita más energía para
estirar este enlace nitrógeno hidrógeno
nuevamente imaginemos que este enlace es
como un resorte si tenemos un resorte
muy rígido o fuerte hay que aplicar más
energía para estirarlo en comparación
con un resorte más flexible
este es el espectro para una mina
secundaria observen que el nitrógeno
está unido a dos carbonos entonces en
una mina secundaria aparece una señal
aproximadamente en 3.300 pero si
comparamos este espectro r de una mina
secundaria con este espectro para una
mina primaria aquí tenemos a la wood y
la mina que es una mina primaria porque
el nitrógeno solamente está unido a un
carbono analicemos el espectro
nuevamente dibujemos una línea en
aproximadamente tres mil sabemos que
esta señal corresponde al estiramiento
del enlace carbono hidrógeno donde el
carbono tiene una hibridación sp3 pero
analicemos la región del enlace con
hidrógeno observen que esta vez tenemos
dos señales esta señal se encuentra
aproxima
la mente en 3300 números de onda y esta
señal se encuentra aproximadamente en
3400 entonces aquí es donde esperamos
encontrar la señal para el estiramiento
del enlace nitrógeno hidrógeno pero
obtuvimos dos señales bueno esto tiene
que ver con el estiramiento simétrico y
asimétrico echemos un vistazo a dos a
minas generales si tenemos un
estiramiento simétrico estos enlaces se
estiran en fase es decir los hidrógenos
se alejan del nitrógeno al mismo tiempo
a eso se le conoce como estiramiento
simétrico simétrico y de este lado
supongamos que estos enlaces nitrógeno
hidrógeno se estiran fuera de fácil es
decir este enlace se estira y éste se
contrae
este es el estiramiento asimétrico
asimétrico entonces por eso obtenemos
dos señales diferentes y como se
necesita menos energía para el
estiramiento simétrico corresponde a la
señal que se encuentra en un número de
onda menor recuerden los números de onda
corresponden a la energía se necesita
menos energía para un estiramiento
simétrico y se necesita más energía para
un estiramiento asimétrico entonces este
ejemplo corresponde a esta señal tenemos
dos señales diferentes en nuestra mina
primaria y tal vez estén pensando o
tenemos dos señales porque tenemos dos
enlaces nitrógeno hidrógeno pero eso no
es lo que ocurre en realidad muchas
moléculas tienen estiramientos
simétricos y algunas moléculas tienen
estiramientos asimétricos por eso
aparecen estas señales diferentes
ahora comparemos rápidamente las aminas
en la mina secundaria solo tenemos una
señal mientras que en la mina primaria
tenemos dos señales así que es
importante tomarlo en cuenta por otro
lado también podemos hablar del
estiramiento del enlace carbono
hidrógeno sp3 por ejemplo si tenemos un
ch 2 dibujaré dos situaciones diferentes
si tenemos un ch todos en alguna
molécula podemos tener un estiramiento
simétrico y uno asimétrico por ejemplo
si estos hidrógenos se alejan al mismo
tiempo tenemos un estiramiento simétrico
y también podemos tener uno asimétrico
el estiramiento asimétrico necesita más
energía así que la señal aparecerá en un
número de onda un poco más alto esta es
una de las razones por las que aquí
tenemos una señal difícil
interpretar se encuentra un poco antes
de 3000 y resulta muy difícil
interpretar pero solo hay que entender
que esto es lo que esperamos encontrar
para el estiramiento de un enlace
carbono hidrógeno donde el carbono tiene
una hibridación sp3 finalmente veamos un
último ejemplo
este es el espectro general para un
anhídrido de ácido entonces dibujemos
una línea en aproximadamente 1500 para
dividir nuestras dos regiones y también
dibujemos una línea en 3000 ahora esta
señal corresponde al enlace carbono
hidrógeno y después tenemos estas dos
señales muy intensas para esta señal
aquí tenemos 1.500 1.600 y 1.700 podemos
decir que se encuentra aproximadamente
en 1760
y aquí tenemos otra señal que se
encuentra después de 1800 así que
tenemos dos señales diferentes que son
muy fuertes y corresponden al
estiramiento simétrico y asimétrico del
carbón y lo en el anhídrido de ácido
porque observen que esta señal se
localiza en la región del doble enlace
ahora la señal que se encuentra a un
número menor de onda corresponde al
estiramiento simétrico así que este
carbón y lo está en fase con este esta
es la señal para el estiramiento
simétrico pero también tenemos un
estiramiento asimétrico en donde uno de
los carbón hilos se estira al mismo
tiempo que el otro se contrae al igual
que un resorte y como se necesita más
energía para un estiramiento asimétrico
corresponde a esta señal entonces si
tienen un espectro y r
y ven estas dos señales tan intensas se
trata del estiramiento del carbón y lo
porque esta es la región que corresponde
al doble enlace estamos hablando del
estiramiento del doble enlace carbono
oxígeno que tiene un momento dipolar
grande y si hay un gran cambio en el
momento dipolar cuando se estira el
enlace aparecen estas señales tan
intensas que en este caso tenemos dos
porque hay un estiramiento simétrico y
uno asimétrico existen otros ejemplos
sobre esto pero espero que esto que
vimos les dé una idea de qué es lo que
pueden encontrar en su espectro y r